yes simu made us all canadians proud
snagging the role of a lifetime as shang
chi and it's written all over his face
so for you to come home here and see
that billboard of you in toronto like
we were seeing this on instagram and it
just must be like a whoa
moment how big of a woman is this for
you there is very much a special meaning
to it i mean this is
home for me in every sense of the word
and his tick-tock game well let's just
say he's got that super power too
[Music]
it's just the hologram like a video game
ludi lynn wowed us as zach taylor in the
power rangers reboot my first action
figure was a power ranger before joining
the dc world as merc in aquaman
and mortal kombat yup ludi is certified
babe status we know you're always in
shape but this is next level stuff what
kind of a task was it for you to
actually put in that work to bring liu
kang to the screen
to stay in shape for a role like this i
really had to hit the ground running
i'm a superhero
is she ever welcome aman valani to the
universe this is crazy i grew up with
you
dude you were my babysitter my mom would
just like leave ytv on
and it was you the canadian newcomer
debuts as kamala khan marvel's first
on-screen muslim hero it's not really
the brown girls from jersey city
you save the world
that's a fantasy too